les chéris c'est un grand jour pour moi
pour vous pondre ce matin j'ai reçu une
boîte une boîte magnifique qui me vient
de youtube youtube une auto buzz et
apparemment il ya un cadeau pour vous
pour nous parce que c'est notre cadeau
on y arrive et c'est suzanne vous
cliquiez c'est la cio de youtube se dire
c'est la patronne de youtube qui m'a
envoyé une vidéo en riant d'autres mots
rien ap à moins qu'alain bonjour
créateur youtube c'est votre chaîne
compte cent mille abonnés un nombre que
très peu de créateurs youtube
parviennent à atteindre en trois mois en
latin nous savons tous que les chiffres
sur youtube par atteindre des sommets
mais nous espérons que vous réalisez
vraiment ce qui se cache derrière ce
nombre à 5 0 les internautes qui se sont
abonnés à votre chaîne pour tous été
touchés par vos vidéos elle il
m'inspirait étonner ou diverti son ami
d'envoi ce soir mon but en travers de ma
vie jamais reçu une lettre comme ça soit
un animal n est donc que mon avis ils
ont mis nous souhaitons récompenser
l'ensemble de votre travail
on vous offrons ce bouton play d'argent
gage de notre estime et de notre respect
oui nous respectable aux états unis
n'arrivent lahbabi les respecter monde à
regarder
wii play d'argent c'est bon bien sûr les
juges commencent
oui elle feint un million d'abonnés peut
vous semble être un objectif
difficilement atteignable pour le moment
les mauvaises vous n'êtes pas si loin et
ils m'ont dit si j'ai ça je vais avoir
un
un truc d'or comme ça le même en or une
bombe atomique
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour vous
soutenir félicitations cratère youtube à
bientôt
suzanne vos skis
voici ce qui bouge ici josy chimiste
c'est suzanne bah voilà égérie ton je
voulais vous remercier une tête d amour
parce que c'est une autre prime jeu
comme how sondés connaissent à tournon
une photo d'où je vais le mettre la
semaine prochaine j'ai pas eu elle-même
et ses bons croyants dites-moi baup a
beau bon et lyon est bien tournera ce
non merci je suis via ne lui